you met you mentioned now good quality
water okay hi this is very important
someone what about here's a gatorade
sports drinks in the morning know what
but electrolytes no no no yeah it's also
got a lot of sugar and it's got
brominated vegetable oil which is really
bad stuff and you know gatorade is not
good not good for rehydrating your body
in fact gatorade typically makes people
want more gatorade it actually makes
them thirsty for more gatorade which if
you think about it from you know a from
the standpoint of of corporate mentality
you know they they want to produce
products that people will consume and
want to consume and keep consuming and
over consume and yeah it's that's best
for their profits yeah what were two
things that has in there that aren't
good for you what was well there's
there's there certainly is there
sweeteners in there there's there's
artificial food dyes there's there's
additives to excite the taste buds in
there that have addictive qualities to
them there's what's something called
brominated vegetable oil bromine
compounds or they can hurt the thyroid
gland the thyroid gland is the gland of
the human body that makes and secretes
hormones that regulate the rate of our
metabolism the rate of our metabolism
has to do with our energy and whether
we're in fat burning mode or fat storing
mode there's other hormones that affect
that as well but you certainly don't
want to do anything that makes life
harder for your your thyroid gland to
function well so the best thing would be
to get these electrolytes in your system
and get you hydrated would be what water
well well filtered tap water you would
want to at the very least get a get a if
you're drinking tap water get a
filtration system that removes the
chlorine and at least most of the
fluoride if not all of the fluoride but
despite the propaganda about fluoride
fluoride is not a nutrient for our
health fluoride as a toxin it's a toxic
substance the fact that fluoride can
have
poisoning effect on our body is is very
evident on every box and tube of
fluoridated toothpaste there is a
warning it says if more than more than
used for brushing is accidentally
swallowed in the amount they're talking
about is not an ice cream scoop amount
of toothpaste but a pea-sized amount of
tooth bases the amount they're referring
to but it says on every box in tube of
fluoridated toothpaste if more than used
for brushing is accidentally swallowed
contact a poison control center right
away so just using a little bit of
logical thinking obviously if fluoride
can have a poisoning effect on our body
it affects much more than our teeth
because no one ever died from poison
teeth and so fluoride is a toxic
substance it's not a nutrient so it's a
good good good thing to do to get a
water filtration system that removes
fluoride you can buy water filtration
systems you can shop for water
filtration systems from friends of water
calm has fluoride removing water
filtration systems and also there's a
company called cuzn calm I went to that
one uuz and yeah you recommend you is
the chemical symbol for coppers ian is
the chemical symbol for zinc they use
copper and zinc materials in their
filtration to to make poor quality tap
water much more supportive of good i use
also berkeley water filter have you
heard of this one yeah oh yes I'm
familiar with that one doubt that they
have a fluoride removing filtration okay
so no tears no to tap water with the
floor yeah well good again unless you
have a filter not non filter tap water
is not not supportive okay would help